die kinder der korona krise seit dem
ersten tag dieser krise berichten wir
hier bei bild über die folgen dieser
schlimmen jahre vor allem für unsere
kinder auch weil die politik die nicht
immer genügend im blick hatte die kinder
jetzt gibt es eine neue schocks studie
von der uniklinik essen und die zeigt
wie der lock down die seele unserer
kinder offenbar kaputt macht als die
schulen im frühjahr 20 21 zum zweiten
mal dicht gemacht wurden dann im winter
haben allein in deutschland 500 kinder
und jugendliche versucht sich das leben
zu nehmen drei mal mehr als vor krone
das sind zahlen die einem das herz
brechen lassen und wir müssen uns fragen
wie kann es weitergehen wie können wir
es endlich ändern dass wir uns alle um
unsere kinder kümmern über dieses thema
müssen wir hier sprechen wir uns im
studio ist sie was willst politik
reporter hallo ich muss wirklich sagen
dass sich diese zahlen gehört habe der
zerbricht etwas das herz in einen ist
dass so viele kinder leiden wenn es so
oft gehört in dieser krise psychologen
fach menschen haben immer wieder gewarnt
vor den auswirkungen eines lockt downs
warum sind diese warnungen so sehr
verhalten das würde ich richtiges haben
ja auch eltern selber gewarnt und gesagt
so kann es nicht weitergehen die politik
hat immer gesagt kinder stehen an erster
stelle tatsächlich war das aber ja nicht
so wir wissen wir haben bis heute zum
beispiel nicht ausreichend luftfilter in
den schulen so etwas das hat man
politisch leider versäumt es wäre jetzt
sehr wichtig dass man davon runter kommt
die ampel sagt ja sie will auch nicht
wieder flächendeckende schulschließungen
machen wir können nur hoffen dass es
dazu auch nicht erneut kommt wir müssen
sagen dieser lockte und diese
schulschließung haben offensichtlich
unsere kinder krank gemacht das ist ganz
dramatisch was wir hier jetzt schwarz
auf weiß in so einer studie sehen wir
stellen heute ihr stellt heute die
provokante frage was ist gefährlicher
jetzt ein neuer omikron lockdown oder
schulschließungen zu welchem ergebnis
kommt ihr also man diese zahlen so sieht
dann müssen wir ganz klar erkennen dann
war für die gesundheit der kinder
tatsächlich die schulschließung
schlimmer denn der beste
gesundheitsschutz für kinder ist
eigentlich zu spielen mit freunden
draußen an der luft zu sein sich zu
bewegen dieses alles das viel jahr
vielfach weg auch in den sportverein das
viel in der schule weg wo man der
freunde trifft kennenlernen
freundschaften überhaupt schließt man
kann freundschaften nicht nur person per
smartphone führen bei kindern passiert
ja sehr viel in der entwicklung das
passiert vielfach in der schule das
passiert auch außerhalb des elternhauses
es ist nicht gut wenn kinder und
jugendliche
festgesetzt sind einfach zu hause in
ihrem kinderzimmer das entspricht nicht
dem was kinder brauchen ihr habt auch
ganz genau und so ein
gesundheitsminister einmal auf die
finger geschaut immer wieder ging es ja
auch um schulschließungen in dieser
krise dass es auch anfangs angesprochen
immer wieder kamen das versprechen noch
von der alten regierung die kinder sind
unsere priorität aber immer wieder hat
sich auch karl lauterbach zu wort
gemeldet als er auch noch nicht
gesundheitsminister war und hat ihr euch
als politik dieser politik soll diese
aussagen mal ganz genau angeschaut
sebastian ja völlig richtig also kalt
bei karl lauterbach finde ich eigentlich
immer gut dass er sich auch mal stellt
und auch seine irrtümer mitunter mal
rockt er hat auch bei bild vielfach sich
schon gestellt und zugegeben ja hier
habe ich falsch gelegen also er hat zum
beispiel mal getwittert am dritten
dezember
sagte er so die daten zu omikron zeigen
zwei entwicklung der durchbruch bei
bereits infizierten und wahrscheinlich
nicht ausreichen gemischten erklärt die
explosion der fälle leider war die
hoffnung verläuft harmloser
wahrscheinlich falsch das war seine
these das ist also eine negative
prognose zu omikron gewesen und die war
einfach verfrüht kurz danach hat das
londoner imperial college nachgewiesen
dass omikron zu 25 bis 30 prozent
weniger klinikeinweisungen führt als
data hat er lauterbach fall spielen aber
es gibt auch noch weitere beispiele die
wir uns mitgebracht hast von karl
lauterbach das ganze hat er abgesetzt
per twitter da war noch nicht
gesundheitsminister aber natürlich schon
einer er der meist bekannten gesichter
die wir auch im fernsehen sehr oft
gesehen haben ja da sagte er zum
beispiel müssen davon ausgehen dass
gerade die omikron variante für kinder
besonders bedrohlich ist hat er am 8
dezember im zdf zum beispiel hier auch
gesagt da widersprechen dem ärzte also
doktor thomas fischbach zum beispiel von
der verband der kinder und jugendärzte
sagte es gibt dazu keine belastbaren
daten
so jetzt hier auch auf kontakt
beschränkungen setzen wir sagte er wir
brauchen den kontakt beschränkungen und
schulschließungen
auch das da ist er sozusagen von der
realität mittlerweile klar widerlegt
worden weil kurze zeit nachdem er diesen
tweet abgesetzt habe seit dem 17
dezember da hatten wir die den
höchststand bei den aus vitali sie
rungen und seitdem sinken diese raten
und zwar ohne das ist weitere krone
einschränkungen gegeben hätten das heißt
der lauterbach wurde hier von der
realität widerlegt in dem punkt also
einmal fazit auch mit blick auf unseren
gesundheitsminister hat die politik in
den vergangenen monaten alles getan
tatsächlich wie sie es versprochen hat
um schulschließungen zu verhindern waren
kinder brio nummer 1
behauptet wird dass aber wir müssen
wirklich wenn wir in die schulen schauen
dann sehen wir immer noch da sind nicht
flächendeckend
luftfilter zum beispiel installiert ich
habe mit fast nirgendwo ehrlich aber
genau also ich hab dann mit dem
grundschulleiter telefoniert darüber der
sagte es ist also so kompliziert dass zu
beantragen er könnte es bei sich zum
beispiel nur beantragen für kellerräume
wo er sagt in solchen räumen sowieso
kein unterricht stattfinden das ist ja
sowieso nicht zumutbar eigentlich meinte
man hat halt offensichtlich darauf
gesetzt dass man keinen cent zu viel
investiert und das ist verheerend wir
sehen was das für dramatische folgen für
kinder und jugendliche hatte und das ist
inakzeptabel und wir können nur hoffen
dass die ampel ihren kurs jetzt hält
wenn sie sagt nicht weiter schulyok
downs die kinder brauchen wirklich etwas
anderes die brauchen bewegung die woche
kontakt zu anderen kindern ja die schule
ist ebenso viel mehr als nur lernstoff
für pauken sondern die schule ist ein
miteinander in soziales lernen freunde
das sind eigentlich die themen die
besonders wichtig sind für ein
glückliches kinder leben danke an unsere
politik reporter sebastian geisler lang
in stans klaren appell an den
gesundheitsminister und an die runde die
sich in kürze zusammensetzt der korona
gipfel am mittag heute mit neuen
beschlüssen und eines auf jeden fall zu
verhindern einen neuen look down in den
schulen